Jennifer Lopez slays the red carpet and
the stage as she'd abused her new single
minute a during the Latin Billboard
Awards
[Music]
Marc Anthony out there in the audience
cheering you on obviously the producer
of this I mean how cool is what makes
him the right producer for this for your
new music I mean there's nobody better
than him and for me in my music you know
I yeah I'm probably his biggest fan and
of his music and honestly to have him
work on the album with me was a you know
scary because I thought you know we're
gonna fight but then I thought there is
nobody else I would want to do that
musical and we've always had great you
know times working together and so it
was great it was your foot we didn't
really it actually made our relationship
even better because we had a lot of fun
together remembered like where we used
to have fun you know where we connect on
a certain level which is through music
and so it was a great thing and I think
it's all there in the album has Alex
heard the new music he had what he says
he loves it he loves it um and I'm so
excited you know every time I finish
something I bring it home and I want him
to hear it and he he's he's so
supportive he's such a supportive person
and he's so lovely and I gotta ask you
about the nickname and whether or not
you like it or it's annoying
j-rod what's the official does JLo give
the official okay um I mean it's fine we
kind of thought that might happen
because people who knew us were already
doing it so you guys it's not like you
were original oh really
yeah yeah like we didn't make it up no
no no
[Music]
you